hey what's going on its bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from March 14th 2016 how you doing how's
it going how are you I had a new blouse
what did you tell you did something
different is there anything worse than
watching somebody do that you know
coming up and they they take the two
women meet right and they grab each
other by the both hands right and then
they look at you and they [ __ ] hold
their hands out I think I've talked
about this before look at you what are
you doing
you know secretly hating the woman
because she looks better you know I
can't you be like guys we just look each
other a guy's a [ __ ] I'm talking about
Oh Billy [ __ ] cuisine over here I
wanted to try to make no key this week
or you know you haven't [ __ ] you're
supposed to pronounce it doesn't seem
too [ __ ] hard right so anyways we got
these old pants right like everything in
my life it's [ __ ] old right I'm old
and everything I own is old because I
bought it when I was young so I guess
the Teflon or whether the no [ __ ] with
you whatever it was Ted scraped off over
the years and was flaking up and
somebody told my leg that it was getting
in our food so now of course oh my god
we got to get ready you know we're
eating Teflon [ __ ] omelets evidently
I don't know I didn't taste it my
[ __ ] arm exponents are rather
delicious I didn't feel any lay no
crunchy like wait a minute what was that
was that was that onions or was that
part of the frying pan I can't tell
mmm it's such a similar taste eggs and
parts of the frying pan you know I don't
know I figured you know if the amount of
booze and I do whatever that that you
know Teflon that went to my system got
eaten up by the [ __ ] my liquid diet
right but whatever so now we got to go
get a [ __ ] frying pan so I go alright
you know we
one nice one and then we had like three
[ __ ] ones so the three [ __ ] ones I guess
we're giving us cancer because someone
who isn't a doctor saw saw the pants and
told us that that was what was what was
happening so we through those ups and
I'm sure those are gonna be [ __ ]
hitting some octopus on the [ __ ] head
when they dump it into the ocean soon
enough so now I'm gonna go buy some more
right I already classic [ __ ]
capitalism it's how it works it's how we
keep it going that's how we keep the
plate to spin it you go out you buy what
you need and then when you have it you
throw it out and then you rebuy it and
the second people stop doing that this
whole country goes down the [ __ ]
that's it that's how simple it is all
these [ __ ] stupid terrorists over
there you know who think they got to
come over here and bomb us all they got
to do is just you just start sending
leaflets over here telling us not to buy
stuff hey wait you already own that you
don't need to buy that keep the money
treat yourself put your feet up don't go
to the ball relax just saying you know
propaganda like we used to know in the
wars right we drop drop little leaflets
you know I would love to read one of
those everything any [ __ ] pictures of
those wartime leaflets to try to get
people like I don't understand how the
[ __ ] you gonna do that like I don't
think I could ever fly over Yankee
Stadium with leaflets telling people to
become Red Sox fans so like how do you
during a [ __ ] war when the country
that's bomb in your country is gonna
send you a leaflet what the [ __ ] does it
say on it yeah hey sorry about most of
your relatives
anyways I you want to come over to our
side we could get you a em sandwich damn
[ __ ] smoky um all right let's see
world war ii leaflets leaflet propaganda
all right let's read a couple leaves let
me see if this would make you [ __ ]
switch sides go from Red Sox to Yankees
or [ __ ] Dodgers to Giants or [ __ ] an
avalanche to the [ __ ] Red Wings or
Michigan do
you get um alright oh Jesus Christ
look at this one why are you German
still fighting not that's that's no way
to get the reader the question is
extremely difficult to answer do they
understand that these people spoke
German
you're gonna write it the Vince is
almost over my head and I speak the
[ __ ] language why you Germans still
fighting I want vile you Germans the
Fuhrer blew his [ __ ] brains out next
to his six of a chick there
the question is extremely difficult to
answer in fact there is no reasonable
answer to it at all you go on fighting
although you cannot I should believe
[ __ ] click on the page here so I can
read this a little bigger oh and then it
always disappears doesn't it always
disappear you just click on it where
they go ok there we go alright you go on
fighting although you cannot help but
realize that Germany is losing the war
Wow Jesus this would make me one of you
eh I've [ __ ] these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you go on fighting although you know
that everyday which the war still lasts
means new destruction to your homeland
new danger and new hardships to your
family you go on fighting although it is
clear that the only people interested in
the prolongation of the war some was
gonna read that a second language I
can't even a prolongation of the war are
the party leaders who want to delay at
any price the consequences which the
Nazi defeat is inevitably going to have
for them personally in other words we're
gonna hang them remember that your dear
ones want you back alive remember also
that there is only one safe way home the
way through allied captivity you know we
had a lot of balls dropping these after
we were fire bombing [ __ ] cities huh
yeah you know we just burned y'all
[ __ ] city to the ground and evidently
you didn't die screaming in agony the
only way for you to avoid that is to
become our prisoner
according to the Geneva Conventions
which has been recognized by Brazil you
will have the following privileges in
allied captivity Jesus this is the this
is the classic checks in the [ __ ] mail
you will be removed immediately from the
battle zone you will get the same food
as Allied troops if six sick you will be
treated in the same hospitals as our
soldiers and after the end of the war
you will go home as soon as possible
well that's pretty vague as soon as we
decide when you can [ __ ] leave
did anybody believe a word of that I
didn't I wouldn't do you know what the
[ __ ] you want these [ __ ] guys are
doing they want us to surrender because
they don't want us to kill more of them
they're just gonna [ __ ] kill us you
know cha he speaks the truth that was me
in a foxhole the Boston accent talking
to somebody who sounds like Hans and
Franz how'd you like that you didn't
think that was coming on the old podcast
there did you the [ __ ] did I start
talking about World War two leaflets I
was talking about buying a frying pan
oh yeah so I get down the street I'm
driving down the old road there okay
it's a Sunday evening I'm like you know
what I'm gonna knock this [ __ ] out
before Monday comes around and all these
[ __ ] have to go to work you know
what I mean
I'm sorry it's an election year all
these hard work had Joe six-packs they
put that anybody who's in my way is in a
that [ __ ] okay and I wish I was more
enlightened to realize that I'm just
impatient but uh that's you know it
hasn't happened yet so anyway so I'm
driving down the [ __ ] Road cruising
along you know and all of a sudden you
know they're doing road construction and
it's just this massive [ __ ] traffic
jam and I knew I had to do the podcast
tonight because I'm doing some [ __ ]
tomorrow morning and I'm just like II
can't get his [ __ ] City can I just
ever give you a [ __ ] break you know I
got to tell you something all this [ __ ]
where they talk about New York you know
if I can
all that [ __ ] you know they're always
blowing New York about how [ __ ]
difficult it is I got to tell you okay
there's an outsider from Massachusetts
I've lived in both places
New York has definitely has its way of
grinding you down but there is no place
like [ __ ] Los Angeles dude this this
[ __ ] city is it's just it's brutal
it's just [ __ ] it never never lets up
you know and then the whole time you're
just bacon in the Sun of the exact same
weather every [ __ ] day and everybody
the East Coast comes out in here four
five six days oh my god this is great
this is great yeah it is great for six
days it's [ __ ] great but every day
waking up and that [ __ ] Sun Sun sign
Sun burn it down on your [ __ ] head
I'm telling you this [ __ ] place and
you combine that with being in this
business that I'm in trying to [ __ ]
move ahead it is it is brutal it's
[ __ ] brutal and all that [ __ ] you
know I can't tell you how many [ __ ]
New York comedians have moved out here
and then move back I moved back first
time I came out of it I couldn't take it
as like I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
I'm telling you they're always so uh you
know New York is so [ __ ] real I'll
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you couldn't
take it you couldn't take it and you
wanted to move back to your familiar
surroundings to only be 20 minutes away
from your grandmother's special sauce
that's why the [ __ ] you moved back all
right
you dumb [ __ ] leather coat the pizza
sucks out here you know I'm telling you
if I had to vote which is a tougher city
to live in I would definitely say yeah
Los Angeles over New York it is [ __ ]
yeah it [ __ ] catches on fire out here
there's mudslides there's [ __ ]
earthquakes you know in New York what's
great about I'm just talking basically
trying to make it in show business to
live in New York in show business which
is what is great about it is is you can
get on the subway and stand amongst a
bunch of regular people real people
right and then you get to feel this
feeling that that you're real that
you're not this big showbiz [ __ ]
phony who wants their own God
TV show yeah New York it's so [ __ ]
real look at that chair look how real
that [ __ ] chair is right
I just think because you know
everybody's all mixed into [ __ ]
together you ride in the subway that
these New York showbiz people they just
automatically think that they're there
you know everybody here is all plastic
and phony because you come out to LA in
the whole place looks like a [ __ ]
movie set right you sit there you know
you'd ride on the subway and you sit
next to some [ __ ] I don't know some
construction worker union guy with this
hard hat getting ready and you start
yeah yeah I'm one of these guys now no
you're not you're in show business
you're a big [ __ ] phony right you're
on your way to puppeteer school or
whatever the [ __ ] it is you're doing
your little song and dance because you
don't want to have a job sorry I
shouldn't have said all that [ __ ] but
you know I I really should have said
that having seen all the [ __ ] that
I've seen like you know Bernie Sanders
talking about I don't what the [ __ ] he
was talking about like I don't think
it's you know a good way to try to bring
black and white people together by
talking about how white people have
never lived in a ghetto because
automatically you're just gonna put them
into a defensive posture where they're
gonna they're gonna sit there and think
about all the [ __ ] that they've gone
through and then they're getting they're
gonna get upset you know what I mean
yeah I don't determine speaking white
people do not live in ghettos although I
think other races of people do not live
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere off of
the Appalachian Trail you know washing
their clothes in a [ __ ] bathtub
sharing a pair of shoes some of that
[ __ ] horrific poverty that I've seen
that most of these [ __ ] politicians
will never see I don't think it's one of
these [ __ ] politicians they should go
on the road and open for a [ __ ]
comedian who's traveling to all these
different thing you will see [ __ ] you
can't [ __ ] believe he'll see levels
of poverty you can't [ __ ] believe
exist in this country I don't want to
name cities but there's some places down
south Jesus Christ I'm on one time I
drove from Indianapolis to Nashville and
there was some place in southern
Kentucky I was running out of gas and I
pulled over and the [ __ ] humanity my
god
I swear to god there was something in
the [ __ ] drinking water I've never
seen it was just like how do I describe
these people without just absolutely
insulting them I don't know it was just
like you know when somebody's like so
dumb you get nervous you know they start
talking to you and they're looking at
you and they're what you're you can tell
they're just smart enough that they know
that you think that they're dumb and
you're trying not to [ __ ] give it
away you know so you just kind of put
your eyebrows up like I am yeah yeah you
try to get out of the [ __ ]
conversation yeah it was like an entire
gas station of that even the person
running the gas station and this was off
a major highway you know there was a
subway you know you know when you drive
in the middle of nowhere you don't ever
go into just some [ __ ] you know
mom-and-pop place you don't want to do
that what you do is you stay you stay
brand loyal you pull into the McDonald's
right you get gas at the [ __ ] Sunoco
or whatever you keep it [ __ ] yeah you
want to get breakfast let's you want to
try the mom and [ __ ] pop place or
everyone's gonna [ __ ] turn around and
look at you are we going to Denny's you
know anyways I really should be talking
about politics cuz I literally do not
watch any of it I know it was all that
[ __ ] with Trump I don't understand
why people won't let Trump speak and how
you feel that that's gonna derail his
campaign I think if anything it'll just
strengthen it I'm sure there's probably
plenty of Trump people that don't like
what Bernie Sanders or Hillary say and
they're not going in in there and
literally disrupting the whole [ __ ]
thing right I don't know just seems
stupid to me he sees a [ __ ] reality
TV show star just let the guy talk gives
a [ __ ] he's not really saying anything
he's appealing to some people who dafuq
votes in a primary anyways aren't you
guys like me I vote once every [ __ ]
four years I hate to say it but I do
I vote once I vote for president that's
why I vote for and I always vote for the
[ __ ] third party person although I
don't know about Bernie Santa I don't
know
[ __ ] vote for this guy I'm just
saying you know hey you know we're gonna
take all the money from [ __ ] these
ten people and give it to all you guys
cuz all you guys deserve it right right
that dumb [ __ ] it's just as it stretched
it's [ __ ] Donald Trump to the left I
can't listen to any of it and then
sitting right in the [ __ ] middle
drafting behind both of them his old
[ __ ] square head herself Hillary
Clinton huh she's gonna [ __ ] I Keys
gonna go right in underneath right in
underneath she's gonna get in there and
you're gonna have listen to that [ __ ]
busted trumpet for [ __ ] the next four
years [ __ ] filthy filthy family I
don't like any of them all three of them
you know what you ever see on the Donald
Trump show when he does like a combo
firing you know what you're fired you're
[ __ ] fired and you're fired that's
what I would like to do with the three
of them toss them in the [ __ ] I can
say that head on cuz I only vote once
every four years and I do not watch the
debates all right so you know I'm
standing on firm ground here such a dope
hey you know what I did do God knows it
wasn't read something I I watched on
Netflix I watched that Ukraine
documentary winter on fire it you know
it was just one of those things was just
like Jesus Christ I knew I wasn't
politically active but watching what
these people did what they turned around
I'll try to give you a simple version of
what happened which you know with my
brain that's all you're gonna get is
basically what happened I guess around
2003 2004 there was some [ __ ] Russian
dude pro-russian dude each claim that he
won the [ __ ] election and they're
like now you didn't get piece of [ __ ]
you rigged it and they proved it and he
got bounced well in 2009 the same dude
comes back and guess what he wins the
election like that wasn't corrupt so
anyways you the Ukraine is a chance to
join the European
in union right to start being more like
a European country and for once and for
all get out from underneath whatever you
call whatever Russia has a dictatorship
so the [ __ ] Russian dude who
allegedly got elected legitimately you
know listens to the people and they say
that that's what we want to do we don't
want to take a step towards Russia we
want to become part of the European
Union we want to have a future here like
what we see going on in Western Europe
and all of the [ __ ] politicians go
you got it
all right the people have spoken we're
gonna do what you said and what do you
think happened right in the midnight
hour they gave me all right there Fred
they're like yeah you know what we're
not sign of that and we're gonna go hang
out with though Vladdy daddy over there
Putin Vladimir Putin and we're gonna
[ __ ] shoot 18 holes of golf with him
and we're gonna sell out your country to
the Russkies so started off this whole
[ __ ] revolution I'm not gonna say
what the [ __ ] I mean you got to watch it
it's unbelievable but um you know I mean
it's family it's not in the news I mean
they ended up winning they somehow ended
up winning and these these [ __ ]
people had no weapons they were just
getting shot at what what I don't
understand I mean I do understand it but
I there's no place in the world where
you can protest you can't do it you
protest cops show up and they beat the
[ __ ] out of you until you go home and
they arrest a few and then that's it
every what happens in this country this
country with all its all with freedom of
speech
you know those [ __ ] Occupy Wall
Street people right they come down there
they beat the [ __ ] out of them and
everybody knows the old trick the same
[ __ ] that they was they were claiming
they did it in the Ukraine where
basically when you have a peaceful
demonstration it's like well [ __ ] we
can't beat the [ __ ] out of them what
should we do they hire a couple people
to go down there and pretend to be the
protesters they throw a couple of
[ __ ] rocks and then the the cops go
nuts and then on the news they're like
the protesters started attacking the
police you know the police we're just
doing their job blow the police's job is
to go down there and beat the [ __ ] out
of them all right isn't it
that what it is that Jesus Christ bill I
don't know bill what do you know I don't
know that's that's kind of what I got
out of it I got out of it that uh it was
an amazing documentary that these people
actually was basically no [ __ ]
weapons and just you know died lost
their eyes had all these horrific
[ __ ] injuries got kidnapped
disappeared all of this horrific [ __ ]
and they were able to hold them off for
a while so then the [ __ ] Russian guy
ends up having a leaf right he [ __ ]
leaves in the [ __ ] over and then all
of a sudden out of nowhere this this
other revolution starts of people who
are Pro Russia so once again all they
did was they just had Russian troops
pretend to be Ukrainians and say wait a
minute we don't want to be free we want
to be oppressed right so now I guess
they're they got to fight that thing and
since they're since with the documentary
made like 6000 Ukrainian people died but
um well I don't understand why if you
just look at the United States of
America the amount of money you can
still make if you're up on top the
amount of taxes you can get out of
paying the amount of perks that you can
[ __ ] have and just pass it on to the
middle class I don't understand why like
why Russia still does the whole [ __ ]
dictator thing or why any country does
just set it up the way we set it up you
pretend that people you know you give
them you know you let them be as free as
they can be you know yeah you do the
whole rhetoric and nothing but basically
there is still a ruling class and you
don't have to pay your fair share and
only [ __ ] share it support so and we
know you're doing it but as long as you
know you let us drive down the street
and it convertible you know listening to
some tunes man but I mean somebody's got
to run it I don't want to [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] you know all of a sudden make
decisions I don't even like running my
own website
no [ __ ] way I could be sitting there
making decisions for in a whole goddamn
country I don't want to do that you know
what uh what the what was that like
every [ __ ] day waking up
not a goddamn problem that's why I think
that'sthat's why you can't have a
dictator that's why they're all so
brutally mean after a while they just
get sick answering questions what's the
problem where I would just [ __ ] shoot
him all right I don't care [ __ ] I've got
to do everything around here
stick a hearing about it anyways
so if you get a chance I'll try to say
is if you get a chance check out a
Ukraine winter on fire
and I don't know I I should really start
paying attention to politics more but I
I just think it's all [ __ ] I can't I
can't sit there and listen to it I start
screaming at the [ __ ] TV and I get
all [ __ ] upset so why would I do that
and then I end up with three [ __ ]
options none of which I want you know I
do have to tell you watch an old fat boy
they're from New Jersey Jesus Christ the
look on his face when he was [ __ ]
listening to Donald Trump that was the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever that looked
like a shotgun wedding and all he was
thinking is that a [ __ ] Atta [ __ ] - I
got it I get myself into this how do I
get out of this you know Jesus Christ
how much did he [ __ ] binge eat that
night poor guy that's really bad it's
gonna be you know what sucks about being
fat is people just know it
you know you can't hide that [ __ ] and
just boom they just [ __ ] right on it
you know what me oh I guess me I'm a
bald-headed [ __ ] so I got that
now but when I was younger
well then I had orange hair orange then
turned red yeah you know I kind of got
[ __ ] the whole time you know if I really
look back at it alright save you just
some regular brown hair brunette [ __ ]
you know I'm just you know when you
think about Chinese people right cuz
they don't they are there any redheaded
like naturally redheaded
naturally-aspirated
Chinese people hang
natural red head Chinese 9 natural
redheads from different backgrounds the
forever war why a Chinese girl has red
hair well because there was a [ __ ]
military base nearby I would think all
right the forever war why a Chinese girl
has red hair when you zoom out of
history to the level where empires rise
and fall and people migrate conquer
collapse and absorb and disappear you
find that the story is always the same
that what the tall stock Thai stock the
original stock is light non-black hernán
brown eyes fair skin well my own a
racist website [ __ ] am i reading here
the others are darker the others are
weaker but breed faster up there we go
then I saw the red flags the [ __ ] is the
name of this website Co annex soul life
to the Neanderthal death to the void
Christus wrecks the forever war why a
Chinese girl has red hair Oh God the
[ __ ] Internet is amazing I just the
fact that he's gives every clue to me
just bunch of [ __ ] dopes why are
blond and red hair colors not seen can
an Asian and a natural redhead have a
redheaded Asian look at this [ __ ] the
redheaded Chinese girl Asian red hair on
Pinterest the world's first Asian
redhead so I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that they don't really don't
have any blondes or any of that type of
[ __ ] so I was just thinking do you think
that people get less [ __ ] like what do
you get bullied for in in China oh god
please let there be some [ __ ] native
Chinese people listen to this what does
it give me the top [ __ ] ten reasons
that Chinese people get bullied in China
it's probably you
[ __ ] economic it's gonna be looks
right there's always gonna be
better-looking mediocre and then there's
always gonna be some poor bastard coming
down the street you know some [ __ ]
happen I don't know something that's
going on with his nose is [ __ ] here
says are there the kids they'll they'll
they'll find something you but you would
think you know if everybody just had the
[ __ ] jet-black hair and maybe I'm
more overly sensitive to this because I
just came you know I came and then I
came in the world with a bull's eye
right right there here you go what the
[ __ ] is that get it right this has been
a [ __ ] crazy podcast huh and I don't
have any advertising yet this is usually
the time that I tap out and I start
[ __ ] reading but it hasn't come in
yet it has not to come in yet let me see
I'll look it up right now see if I got
it enough why do I always have 50
[ __ ] windows open no I got a French
book here that I was reading I wasn't
reading I was listening to it
there's a book something bought a wolf
that wanted to change its colors I've
gone 15 or 16 straight days on duolingo
ask me to say something French I can't
really but you know what I can read it
pretty well for I know that that means
for children poor off false children all
right what am i doing I'm gonna
completely losing my train of thought
here oh [ __ ] he's something there's a
window this is the amount of [ __ ] I look
at one window I have French school books
all right and then the next window I
have critical engine opened up on
Wikipedia I was talking to Paul virzi
cuz we're doing this tour and I was
saying like alright these are gonna be
like four or five hour drives or we
could rent a small plane but it's gonna
be maybe two to st. Paul's Miata
look the only small plane starts
freaking the [ __ ] out right like small
planes thinking it's like a Chevy
Chevette it's a piece of [ __ ] like it's
not it's gonna die and I was saying like
- it's gonna be a dual engine we're
gonna be [ __ ] fine you got two
engines I mean the odds are them both
[ __ ] failing at the same time and one
of them can still fly the plane you find
this is what I believed but then I
started looking it up because I was
trying to give him some information I
was saying like look I mean I don't know
hundred percent know
the ship this is what I've basically
been told and I started looking it up
and evidently one engine for the most
part is more critical than the other and
also when one engine goes out it isn't
like you just keep flying it normally
well you know we still got one we're
good
like dead obviously you know it [ __ ]
with the not the balance what would it
be I don't know how to say it
scientifically it's not a jet engine so
there's no like thrust is there Jesus
Christ can you believe I have a pilot's
license a [ __ ] I believe all right
let's read this here the critical engine
of a multi engine fixed-wing aircraft is
the engines whose failure would most
adversely affect the performance or
handling abilities of an aircraft on
propeller aircraft there is a difference
in the remaining yong and that's just
the nose going right to left moments
after failure of the left or the right
outboard engine when all propellers
rotate in the same direction due to the
p factor and i was like what the [ __ ] is
the p factor and it has something to do
with like when you're flying straight
and level flight okay your propeller
blades are you know they're they're you
have the angle of attack with the wind
it's basically coming straight you're
perpendicular to the angle of attack of
the wind that way you are getting the
most bang for your buck with for the
work that the engine is doing with the
propellers but the more you angle nose
up or nose down the more the wind the
way it's hitting it affects the
performance is what I sort of believe I
got all this mumbo jumbo in my [ __ ]
head I have no idea but I had no I so I
started reading more about this and
there's all these [ __ ] debates you
know I was always of the belief that if
you had two engines if you could afford
two engines you buy that [ __ ]
airplane because you know the engines
run independently so you got to [ __ ]
engines what are the odds of both of
them one fails and then the other one
[ __ ] fails you know but it's it so
it's got to be almost zero
however there's all these that I could
you know something I started to read
about it and there was all these de
we're at first it was obviously believed
that yet more engines is better is safer
and then somewhere along the line
somebody did a study and saw that more
fatal action actually more fatal
accidents happened in dual engine
aircraft and people were going like oh
and then it so may be a single is better
and then that person came back was like
no you weren't
hearing what I was trying to say I was
actually saying it was safe and then it
doubled back on itself and I have no
[ __ ] clue what is safe but what I did
learn in it in a very layman kind of way
was I had no idea that I mean it does
make sense if you just have one side
working you know that it'd be sort of
pulling that side along of the aircraft
more so than the other one causing the
other one to drag and I left I don't
know crab your way into the [ __ ] wind
I have no idea but all I know is I was
reading it says if one of your engines
dies and the other ones still going you
obviously have a much they said a much
better chance of making it to the
airport they didn't say you would make
it though and which but here's my
question to anybody out there who might
know this [ __ ] on it on your average
twin-engine airplane can boat both
engines independently fly the airplane
you know what I mean
with one quick that they both have the
ability to get basically get you have
you flying fast enough where you can
still maintain lift you know because
then I was then thinking like okay well
if they went from one to two engines you
know you're adding more weight to the
aircraft well I guess you'd build a
bigger [ __ ] plane sorry I'm trying to
do this math oh my head you build a
bigger [ __ ] plane but my thing is is
do they then go oh because of on certain
aircraft because it's a cheaper
twin-engine it's that both engines in
unison have enough power so you can
maintain lift but if you lose one of
them the other one can't still give you
the hundred percent of the lift that you
need you actually only have like sixty
percent if you still have the critical
or only 40% if the critical one goes out
like I have no idea how that works all I
know is it scared the [ __ ] out of me
that's all I could tell you all right
isn't it amazing the amount of topics I
can talk about that I have no [ __ ]
idea it's incredible but we're gonna be
doing some more here in the last
half-hour this podcast I guess now in
which I'm just gonna say that I'm gonna
stop here and read some advertising I
don't have it but you're gonna hear it
now because you're listening to this and
the [ __ ] future okay Dualla shade
Club everybody I'm recording this on my
phone if it sounds [ __ ] up alright
dollarshaveclub.com has a special offer
for a new members four new members who
joined today you'll get a free month of
the executive razor when you buy a tube
of doctor this is the first time they've
ever done something like this and once
you try dollarshaveclub.com you'll
become a proud member like millions of
others one reason is because they
deliver amazing razors right to your
door for a third of the price of what
those greedy [ __ ] razor corporations
charge that means when you join Dollar
Shave Club you can afford to shave with
a fresh blade anytime you [ __ ] goddamn
well feel like and it feels fantastic
you'll get a first-class shave when you
use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet another reason is their
doctor calf is easy they're using it
with the executive makes the blade glide
gently over the smoothest shave ever hey
you might want to shave your balls with
it don't do that don't do that nobody at
[ __ ] skin shave head dollar shave
club is saying to [ __ ] do that that
was a joke okay drop your razor and wash
the Kavi shave butter off of your ball
bag do not do it
all right back to the end dr. kay vzz
Shimada isn't your average shaving cream
it's a unique conditioning formula with
high quality natural ingredients leaving
you're leaving your skin unbelievably
soft and smooth and right now members
who buy a tube of shave butter get the
executive razor razor for free they've
never done this before take advantage of
it and it's seal it's only of
available by going to Dollar Shave Club
calm / burr thats dollar shave club calm
/ burr
alright what's up next oh here we go our
old friends are back headspace man let's
be honest most of you most of your
problems start with your mind Jesus I
know mine do fear anger stress anxiety
depression sleeplessness and freckles
they begin in your head they can wreck
your life please include all the
following points during your read I will
I always do but it doesn't have to be
that way you can make a major difference
in just 10 minutes a day this change
comes through a through guided
meditation with the new headspace app
headspace man is meditation made simple
its guided meditation that you listen to
whenever you want wherever you want
right on your phone computer or tablet
meditation is rooted in thousands of
years of tradition and we've boiled that
we've boiled it down to an app that we
hope a bigger corporation will someday
buy so we can pop that we can take the
money get some hookers and a bunch of
blow with thousands of scientific
studies that show its positive effects
like improving focus and relationship
harmony and decreasing anxiety and
stress join over 5 million users already
using some headspace me and for free
right now for free download for free
headspace the headspace app begin to
take their take 10 program for 10 days
of guided meditation at headspace calm /
/ why don't I ever do this I need to do
this I'm out of my [ __ ] mind the
headspace take 10 program is 100% free
way to experience the benefits of
meditation in your busy modern life
train your mind for a healthier less
stress life that would be great for me
you know
I'd stop screaming to people I wouldn't
be funny anymore and I'd become homeless
but god damn it I'd be happy now
seriously I want to do this head
space.com slash birth that's headspace
calm
/ / hey man head space.com slash /
[ __ ] there's two more I hate this I hate
doing these trunk club no matter what
time of year it is yeah you got to make
every second count
oh [ __ ] I need to look good with this
zipper and that means looking your best
no more ratty jeans or oversized Hildy's
your dress like a [ __ ] douche G
wouldn't be great if a trunk full of
clothes would come your way sure I know
how you could do it trunk club trunk
club takes the hassles man out of
shopping finding the best clothes for
you and your style you look and feel
amazing and you'll always have the
perfect clothes for the season but I
don't want to go to the [ __ ] mall
well that's the point of the ship at
trunk club.com / / you answer simple
questions about your style your
preferences your size and you are
assigned an expert stylist your stylist
is going to go pick up all the [ __ ] that
you asked for then they're going to send
you the [ __ ] trunk you sift through
it you keep a [ __ ] you like you give
this [ __ ] back that you don't like in
their prepaid [ __ ] trunk
bing-bang-boom you never have to go to a
mall again you're gonna look great
goddamn it you look great you feel great
maybe you'll summer it'll suck your dick
maybe you'll find your prince charming
sorry I had to cut through all the
coffee get started today at trunk club
and they'll styie for free plus trunk
free shipping both ways you can only pay
for the clothes that you keep take
advantage go to trunk club com / /
that's trunk club.com / / for a trunk
filled with clothes you're gonna love
you don't have to go to the mall it's a
[ __ ] joke why you're not doing it I
don't know
alright blue apron everybody you need to
know how to cook okay it's time you grow
up and learn how to cook not only do you
feel like you know your way around a
kitchen
whoo-hooo fillings Fathy but cooking at
home means eating healthier and saving
more money instead of ordering out
expensive takeout again hey man where do
you start
well don't worry blue apron as you
covered for less than $10 per meal blue
aprons a blue apron delivers all fresh
ingredients all the fresh ingredients
you need to create home-cooked meals
just follow the easy step-by-step
instructions each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less no overwhelming
trips to the grocery store no more sad
takeout no matter your dietary
preferences blue apron makes it a breeze
to discover and prepare dishes like
smokey maple miso glazed salmon with um
what dude on noodles Adan noodles
you've done noodles you'd on doodles you
do and noodles mushroom kale and cheese
quesadilla gross gross mushroom and kale
and cheese look it's like watching a fat
kitty paste how about chicken and cheese
with lime sesame avocado radishes and
salsa right now in your own kitchen you
can cook with the grease that you've
never used before like watermelon
radishes Pharaoh far oh [ __ ] oh I don't
know what it is with purple potatoes and
recipes are between five and seven
hundred calories so you won't become a
fat [ __ ] delicious and good for you
right now you can get your first two
meals for free at blue apron calm / /
that's blue apron calm / / high blue
apron calm / / you know what it's a
better way to cook god damn it and there
you go back to the podcast yet constant
in the future alright um oh I didn't
even finish the [ __ ] I'm back we're
back after the advertising we are back
I guess did I read it that I sound good
now how much did I stumble I never even
finished the frying pan story so I get
all the way down to the [ __ ] frying
pan thing alright and we already have
like the regular whatever 10-inch one so
I want to buy the 8-inch one that
matches and of course the only way to do
that is I have to buy the whole [ __ ]
set you know I was just like you know
what [ __ ] you and I bought one of those
little pasta cutter thinks and that was
it I [ __ ] left I could for the life
we could understand one of them was 995
the other one was 21 bucks and I sat
there for 10 minutes holding both of
them trying to see like what is a handle
better how is this one more than twice
the price I don't know bill why would
you think it's interesting to us I don't
know trying to fill up a [ __ ] hour
here by the way by the way I got some
like I have I do have some dates and I
will never again announce cities that I
that I'm saying you know we're working
on it I'm never gonna do that again like
I said what I said with Buffalo and
[ __ ] Syracuse because that hasn't
worked out yet now everybody's like dude
what the [ __ ] you said you were coming
there I shouldn't open my big Yap
alright I am coming to Albany I do know
that so
people in Buffalo like to that's like a
for our [ __ ] Drive I know I know I'm
sorry all right
oh I'll figure something out all right
here we go on March 25th I'm in
Riverside California Riverside which I
believe is the beginning of the Inland
Empire or maybe it isn't I have no idea
on the 26th I'm at the Terrace Theatre
in Long Beach California unbelievable
honored to be playing the place that is
the place where Richard Pryor taped live
in concert where he had the red shirt at
the black pants and the silver shoes I
will be standing on that stage I'm sure
they redid it since he's been there you
know so I won't be standing on the exact
same floorboards but I will be within
the same structure I would be standing
in the same place where he did stand-up
comedy to me the greatest stand-up
comedian of all time on the 22nd of
April I will be in st. Louis on the 24th
he's a great ones I will be in Iowa in
Ames Iowa 22nd st. Louis Missouri and
the 24th I'll be in Ames Iowa I have not
been in Iowa since I did the rich-bitch
tour way back in 2004 speaking of which
is anybody's think one of the guys I did
the tour at Donnell Rawlings did you see
that TMZ video the guys getting
breakfast he's got a 12 dollar check he
goes outside to have a cigarette he
leaves his bag inside all the sudden
that came running out in Philly
screaming and I'm picking he was he was
dining and dashing but as we used to
call it in Boston you know I mean
[ __ ] unbelievable I'm believing the
ends I'm getting a big [ __ ] fight
knowledge he's got his bag inside they
won't give it to him according to the
[ __ ] that I read I it's just [ __ ] I
believe and I could tell you that as a
white guy that would not happen to me
that would not happen to me that was
that was [ __ ] up definitely [ __ ] up
and you know what it didn't happen in
Boston all right all you [ __ ] haters
it happened in Philly say it's all
around you know it was funny Donald
threw that
and the dude caught it the next time I
see him I'm gonna tease them about that
I wouldn't do it now because it's
[ __ ] fresh and it was [ __ ] I
can't I can definitely tell you as a
white dude that you know that not we
would not have happened maybe that's a
complete racial profiling incident but
it was that [ __ ] dude leaned back and
just caught it you know you ever see a
pitcher just catch a [ __ ] one that
comes right back to the mound he did
that but with Donnell's fist
anyways plowing ahead may 7th Orlando
Florida may 8th I'll be in Jacksonville
Florida and Clea what are you staring at
before what's the matter I'm not already
gave you F ood so don't even look at me
like that I already took you out well
you just want attention buddy you
getting lonely over there huh
all right [ __ ] dog is so needy
alright Portland May June 4th 2016 I'll
be there and I also know I in the early
April I got a bunch of Canadian dates
they're all up on my website
billboard.com so anyway speaking of dogs
I kind of tweeted about this [ __ ] where
you know what the [ __ ] dog I have the
biggest problem with like their owners
never have money control I'm not blaming
the breed here but there's just
something about the [ __ ] the owners
and how hyper the dog is is those
[ __ ] giant poodles there was another
one today I was at the supermarket this
person had tied it up outside and it's
just literally outside the [ __ ]
supermarket the whole time would not
stop sorry I get my dog all amped up
those [ __ ] dogs are insane I don't
know what the deal is with them be they
I think they like they're kind of like
greyhounds I'd really just think you
need to run them around a [ __ ] track
for an hour every day just to get him to
get it out of their system but they got
like that perm going on so I don't think
anybody really thinks it's an issue Cleo
what are you doing you're going
distract me on the podcast you can't be
this adorable right now okay for those
you don't know anything about pitbulls
they are like the most needy [ __ ]
like love bugs they're ridiculous like
she just wants to crawl up here and
[ __ ] put a head in my lap and go to
sleep you know what I mean she's not
over in the corner [ __ ] doing some
prison workout thinking about you know
people she wants to kill or in that
right buddy
now that I have stereotyped giant
poodles I'm gonna try to undo the damage
with pitbulls who's getting home my dog
would try to rip your face off if he
came into the [ __ ] you know the house
she [ __ ] barked at a guy yesterday
and I actually loved every second of it
I was sitting in my Prius on these mean
streets of Los Angeles downtown
Hollywood and some [ __ ] degenerate
came up to the window and I don't know
what the [ __ ] he's asking for money or
booze or some [ __ ] and my dog just
[ __ ] flipped out flipped out the guy
jumped back and everything was great
it's like having my own security and the
guy was such a [ __ ] alky he backed up
off the car and then still mimed like
I'm I want to drink I'm trying to get
some money for drinks
I just you know I told to beat it every
once in a while I'd tell him to beat it
you know there was a one-legged homeless
guy and he seemed like he was saying and
he was talking to himself maybe he was a
little crazy but I would be talked to
myself too if I had one [ __ ] leg
standing next to a stop sign right what
else you gonna do there's nobody else
there so him I gave money to and I was
actually joking to myself when I gave
him the money and I drove away I go
there's my good deed for the day let's
go rub and tug I can't believe [ __ ]
people go to those places man don't you
worried that the cops are gonna show up
any second you know you lying there with
the [ __ ] woody I'm a little [ __ ]
Woodrow Wilson right some girl [ __ ]
giving you all handy and all of a sudden
everybody you know you're like God [ __ ]
right
and what are you gonna do say it was
legal you know will that
hard-on to go away before that [ __ ]
dude comes in and sees you with half a
stiffy you know I swear to god it hangs
like that I was in here I had a problem
my shoulder man they're gonna arrest you
this your [ __ ] half-naked bring you
down to the jail you're already ready to
get [ __ ] you don't have any clothes on
you got oil all over your body the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
so anyways June 5th I'll be in Albany
New York and June 17th I'll be in no one
no work [ __ ] New Jersey at the New
Jersey [ __ ] performance Art Center
for the the [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
you know really made me happy the day I
was watching the NHL Channel obviously
they were talking about how the Bruins
could potentially get the number one
seed in the East
un-fuckin'-believable the job that
Claude Julien has done and I'll tell you
something right now remember last year
when you were calling for his [ __ ]
head and saying maybe he stayed here too
long you all want to know and you should
write an apology article unbelievable
how these [ __ ] sports writers because
they got nothing else to write well
we'll try to run out run out of town a
[ __ ] coach who brings us our first
Stanley Cup in almost 40 [ __ ] years
why would you do that jesus [ __ ]
christ why would you do that all right
let's uh let's read some of the the
questions here for this week oh we got
an update I love when there's an update
remember last week the the granny [ __ ]
and remember that story all right here
we got an update hey there old Billy
[ __ ] water I got an update for you on
this one
the story has good news and bad news all
right so lash last week for those of you
who didn't listen I'll give you a little
recap there was some kid you know he was
he's basically he's engaged he's getting
married in six weeks so he's over his
fiancee's house as in his future in-laws
house her [ __ ] parents that's all I'm
trying to say right so they're playing
some card game and evidently they're
down to the final hand in
he has the cards called granny water I
don't know what the game is or whatever
some people sent me pictures of the card
the game does exist but it's a really
high point card or whatever and he was
laying down
welcome Yannick sorry he was laying down
his card last and basically when he laid
it down he was gonna do the old [ __ ]
right there fret I won the game and he
had the granny water card and I guess in
the end of the game is probably you get
it you hold on to it you played at a
crucial point
so everybody's sitting there as
everybody's laying the cards down
waiting to see who's gonna [ __ ] lay
it down so this kid [ __ ] it's finally
his turn he lays it down to be like you
know like hit in the last second three I
just won and because he listens to the
podcast instead of saying I got the
granny water card he goes he goes look
he goes it's all [ __ ] great now he
goes it's granny [ __ ] water and just
screamed it to his in-laws okay who
never heard this guy curse before and do
not listen to this podcast so they just
stared at him like oh what what was that
what is my daughter marrying like he
just completely screwed the whole
[ __ ] thing up so he's asking me for
advice should he bring it up should he
not bring it up all right now you guys
have caught up here you go
he says the story has good news and bad
news the good news is my fiance's
parents were super cool about the whole
things I bit the bullet and waited until
we went over for game night again last
night
I apologized of course and they said
they initially just thought well you're
like this [ __ ] they initially thought it
was really odd for me to yell like that
without knowing without them knowing the
context but once it was explained my
fiancee texted them about it it was no
big deal it was a huge relief we played
the game again and every time someone
played that card they did the whole
granny water thing - the [ __ ] in the
middle okay cool he goes so my
embarrassment will be immortalized the
bad news is that I mentioned that you
read the letter on the podcast
no you know what you're one of those
guys dude you just like you just like
step in and [ __ ] he goes naturally they
wanted to listen to it I thought it
wasn't a big deal because they lived
through the story and your commentary
was hilarious I warned them about the
explicit nature of your podcast and that
there were plenty of [ __ ] throughout
the fact that he did the granny water
thing before it was even brought up was
perfect everyone thought the story was
hilarious that is until the PS if you
recall I may or may have not called
Hillary Clinton a [ __ ] Jesus that's
right you did he goes yeah I know I'm a
dumbass bill my fiance just turned to me
and said did you write that he said my
fiance turned to me and said did you
write that with that look on her face I
knew I was [ __ ]
so freckles I did the only thing I could
I said oh sorry about that I didn't
write it
bills email screener guy did Andrew did
he picks the emails each week then
writes the little opening line pun and
then sometimes throws in a PS to make
them more entertaining well now why
would you write this because if they
listen to this you're [ __ ] you don't
do it I have no sympathy for you so here
we go he goes they bought it so we just
listened to the rest and we're laughing
again by the end so I threw Andrew under
the bus on that one I'm going to repeat
my only good move from the last story
and just shut the [ __ ] up about it
forever in the end all is well thanks
for reading it out in the podcast it
seemed to help smooth it over no worries
just tell him not to listen to this one
he goes by the way I just bought tickets
to your show and I'm not going to say
where the show is in case anybody's
figuring out of the [ __ ] this is it's
the week after my wedding and my fiance
slash wife by that point is coming to
I'd love to meet you in person thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself alright will you
I'll be hanging out after the Iowa just
scream out I just said where it was
oh well you're [ __ ] granny water
screaming out and I'll [ __ ] say hello
to you
alright now everybody's gonna do that
there all right girlfriend leaving Cleo
relax buddy no cold you knows this it's
usually not cold at night you got a
little gas left in the tank huh you want
to go all right okay I got it I'm not
gonna say the whole sentence I will I'm
gonna take you know who you know where
when I'm done with this all right
Cleo go lay down buddy could you please
lay down I don't have it in my heart to
yell at you here all right could you lay
down your [ __ ] bastard get out go on
go on please can you lay down please
Cleo yeah yeah step on all my [ __ ] as
you go over there just go lay down
Jesus dog whisperer I am NOT well by the
way how about those [ __ ] [ __ ] it
wounded warriors how much money did I
give them if they're actual pieces of
[ __ ] over there and they didn't give
that [ __ ] money to wounded troops you
know can I sue them to get the money
back and then just give it to the
[ __ ] people they were allegedly gonna
help I am I am really just I'm done I'm
done with [ __ ] charities I'm [ __ ]
done with them
I just damn you know I'm going Donald
Trump on this one I've seen two or three
bad ones and now I'm judging all of them
[ __ ] them
Saint Jude I'm sticking with them okay
if they end up turning foot that bad
then [ __ ] all of them I'm just doing why
I'm doing what I did the other day drove
up to somebody with one leg at a
stoplight observed that they weren't
[ __ ] wasted as much as I could tell
and there you go you know even if they
were I'd be drinking too if I had one
leg right standing at a [ __ ] stop
sign I know what the stop sign has to do
with it what was it traffic light though
well then you know maybe I have some
yogurt girlfriend leaving for a
religious mission hey Billy ballbag my
girlfriend and I are both college
students and although we haven't been
together for too long I could tell she
is special in the way when you meet the
one you just know she's the person I
have she's the
person I've ever met kind funny
intelligent and on top of that just
drop-dead gorgeous well Jesus locked
that down - if things seem to be too
good - true what if things seemed too
good to be true Jesus Christ I am sorry
I gotta have some form of [ __ ] mild
dyslexia or I'm even dumber than I
thought honey it's a rough one uh things
seemed too good to be true they are
she's Mormon Oh Gigi and she's leaving
for her mission in July
if you don't know Mormons
I don't give a [ __ ] about Mormons they
just anybody who's actively religious
you know to the point it affects the
decisions they make in life other than
basic [ __ ] like you know don't throw a
rock at that guy because you wouldn't
want to do it to you you know I am along
with that but well you know when you
start forming other opinions on your
[ __ ] religion it starts to get a
little Sian Tala Christy Judy Buddha
[ __ ] ISM whatever throw them all in
[ __ ] muslin and it's a big [ __ ]
pot you can stick it all in a [ __ ]
pot right yeah there you go shower the
microwave right turn it on and don't
shut it off all right she's a Mormon and
she's leaving for her mission in July
if you don't know Mormons are a type of
Christian I didn't know that and they
send missionaries around the world to
convert people into their religion and
she's getting sent to Zimbabwe [ __ ]
Zimbabwe they leave for two years have
to pay for everything themselves
and aren't allowed to contact home the
entire time why aren't they allowed to
contact home the entire time that's
[ __ ] weird if she goes not only would
that be the end of us but it seriously
hurts chances of her future career
aspiration we both want to become
doctors I'm an atheist but I've recently
found myself praying to Jesus that she
doesn't actually go because if and when
she leaves that will be the end of it I
don't know what to do should I break
things off now should I try and convince
her not to go waiting is not an option
for me because we'd be completely
different people by the time she gets
back
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself um I don't
know do it I'm starting to think maybe
she isn't the one for you if you're just
gonna you know if you have to debate
telling her not should I just break it
off or tell her not to go I mean I think
if she really loved this woman you would
you be going I'm just gonna talk to her
till I'm blue in the face and tell her
not to go and then even if she went
you'd be thinking like well maybe you
know you'd have a ray of light going
well maybe to two years I don't know if
we agreed a [ __ ] cool it for two
years you know it's only two years when
you look at the rest of your life you're
kind of like yeah we pick two completely
different people and [ __ ] break it up
now yeah look she wants to go to
Zimbabwe let her you know to spread the
[ __ ] word of whatever the [ __ ]
they're doing there yeah let it go just
you know listen somebody wants to go
somewhere to go do something what are
you telling not to go go ahead you know
go go go spread the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
they put in your head and go go go
spread it on the other side of wells
poor [ __ ] Zimbabwe people
Zimbabwean people now you went [ __ ]
Zimbabwe yeah no I was assuming you
meant because it's so far away you
couldn't visit her let's see what's
going on and said Bob way right now
Zimbabwe that's exactly how it should be
spelled zi m ba BWA I'd be such a great
[ __ ] speller if everything was spelt
like Zimbabwe Zimbabwe CIMB a b w e--
zimbabwe zimba will be converting you to
mormon doo doo doo you got two years of
your life to [ __ ] for what all right
Zimbabwe said Bob ways a beautiful
country in southern Africa that is known
for its dramatic wait wait wait come on
oh this is the government this is the
government website so this is all the
propaganda here yeah that's absolutely
beautiful you have your wallet [ __ ]
tape to your chest no one will take it
everybody's wonderful down here
everybody's welcome please come down and
spend all your [ __ ] money you know if
you don't mind see Bob Way was voted the
number one place in Zimbabwe to go three
years in a row Wow Jesus look at that
[ __ ] that puts Niagara Falls to shame
holy [ __ ]
Zimbabwe is a beautiful country in
southern Africa that is known for its
dramatic landscapes its diverse wildlife
see cobras and tigers and it's
hardworking people home to the great
zimbabwe monument the mighty Victorian
falls and the majestic Eastern Highlands
the country also boasts of world-class
national parks in which a variety of
animals including the Big Five can be
found the big what-the-fuck of the big
five big five I got to go lion who's
your big five it's like the Chris Rock
movie top five give me a big five I'd
say the big five you got to go lion
tiger elephant bout adout right that's
like Montana Brady and Johnny Unitas the
third one you never know right
whatever they're in everybody's top five
if you know anything about football
right all right lion tiger elephant
hippos rhinos giraffes are big gorillas
some big [ __ ] hang on a second
I gotta look up Big Five this is how you
doing what you know I'm gonna get this
Sports Club big 5 sporting good big five
animals in Africa all right in Africa
the big 5 game animals are the African
lion the African elephant like I says
African you know like what as opposed to
what the Rhode Island one they wanted
the [ __ ] zoo the Cape Buffalo ah
the African Leopard aha and the white
slash black rhinoceros all right so I
got three all right I said hippo rhino
well where the [ __ ] the hippo big 5
game
all right an Africa the big five game
animals are American ok the lion the
elephant the Buffalo the leopard and the
rhinoceros oh is this the thing that
dentist pay to fly over and go [ __ ] and
shoot these things alright alright so
there you go
so we learned a little something here
that's the big five the largest of these
are the National Park in the West and
the something else Trane's frontier Park
in the south has a total area of three
or nine thousand engine alright let's
get to the let's get to the real
questions Americans welcomed in Zimbabwe
did we do anything our did the upper 1%
in this country piss them off
alright Americans in Zimbabwe that that
that uh it is are you looking for fellow
Americans in zip-up no I'm not looking
for a [ __ ] pen pal six things I had
wrong cos last thing a read about
Zimbabwe yeah alright six things I had
wrong about traveling to Zimbabwe look
at those elephants [ __ ] love listen I
cannot believe people kill those things
how could you kill an elephant I
couldn't kill any of those [ __ ] pigs
alright the top five things six things I
had wrong about travellingtans and Bob
way and one I had right number one
Zimbabwe is dangerous at Matador we
believe most travel advisories and
American perceptions of overseas
destinations being dangerous our way
overblown I enjoy visiting seda today
the big cities big cities are the are
where the most violent crime is
concentrated like in the United States
it wasn't a surprise that then that
Victoria Falls as well as the couple
national parks we visited felt it just
about as safe and as friendly as any
place can get in fact Victoria Falls has
such a small-town feel that other
journalists joked it had the vibe of US
National Park in the offseason alright
cool
Zimbabwe wildlife has all been wiped out
this was a big one for me
I love seeing wildlife
this is making me want to go there three
hyperinflation will make buying things a
total hassle and after seeing years of
new coverage hyperinflation especially
uh I'd have to carry around bricks of
$10 ten billion dollar notes to buy a
bunch of beer but the currency of
Zimbabwe has become so worthless they've
retired it completely and the country
now operates on a mix of foreign
currency including the South Africa okay
beyond the wildlife there's not much to
do or see there's rafting bungee jumping
microlight flying over victory fall
fishing swimming all right well what the
[ __ ] did you get right I'm not reading
all this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ] video
swimming and Victoria Falls get the [ __ ]
out of here this is this thing that
looks like it's bigger than Niagara
Falls no [ __ ] way
[Music]
so basically the water isn't flowing
fast enough that these [ __ ] guy okay
I got to put a send a link to this video
who is the absolute [ __ ] psycho that
figured out you could do that dude if
you just saw the pasty fat [ __ ] white
dude who just jumped in there you know
it's funny he's there with two [ __ ]
two black guys man he'd be funny if they
grabbed him and threw him over that was
for slavery let me all right I got a
copy of that Jesus Christ what a [ __ ]
lunatic there's no no way there's no
[ __ ] way no [ __ ] way all right
let's get back to the things here all
right where am I all right tinder Oh
Billy let's read some emails for the
week I hooked up with this girl I met on
tinder the first in years I'm not a bad
looking guy I'm not a bad looking guy I
think I just suck at small talk over or
over text
anywho this girl is 21 I didn't expect
it to go anywhere after we matched up
but we ended up hooking up she's really
cool he hung out a few times since my
friend and his girlfriend started saying
that was gross I am 30 years old
now I know my friend is being lame
because his girlfriend was there but
gross not at all so I let them have
their ignorant opinions then I dropped
the facts of him she looks more like
she's 24 through this really doesn't
help with you I look like I'm 25 that's
also not helping you
she took extra classes to graduate
college early and has already accepted
into medical school still not helping
you she speaks four languages fluently
well I see what you say and she's not a
dumb [ __ ] she knows what she's doing I
don't mean hello and goodbye she can
carry on full-on conversations and
Mandarin French and Italian as well as
English of course she has much better
table manners than both of them oh you
said that wow you just torched the whole
friendship I pointed this out to my
friend's girlfriend who didn't have a
napkin on her lap and her elbows were on
the table and pointed that very fact out
to her as well also I mentioned that
when me and this girl met for a drink
she put her napkin on her lap before she
bought her drink to her mouth which
would have hovered over her lap
awareness levels maximum 21 who gives a
[ __ ] I like to think I'm right and then
I made a good point but I need the
opinion of your honor Billie burr yes
[ __ ] damn you're 30 she's 21 who gives a
[ __ ] good for you you [ __ ] crushing
it she's a [ __ ] adult and she's not a
dope you didn't roofie her and they're
two miserable [ __ ] in a relationship
all right we got food coming out of the
side of their mouth carry on all right
my kid wants to play football hey Billy
Bella check Bella Bella lick I'm a huge
football fan watch every week yada yada
yada my kid is seven and loves it too he
plays baseball and basketball and is
really fast we play catch with the
football in the year and he's really
fast which has given him the desire to
be a wide receiver granted it's not the
worst pounder you can get on the field I
don't want him playing football he's a
great athlete but I'm not one of those
delusional dads who thinks he's going
pro in whatever he does he's not small
but definitely not the biggest of his
age group how do I not sound like a
cranky old man or worried old mother and
explained to him how it's not worth it
should I just show him footage from a 34
thirty to scare the [ __ ] out of him oh
man dude that is such a contemporary
question relevant question whatever you
know I would actually defer this to the
Internet believe it or not and then you
have to use your own judgment as to
whether you're listening to somebody who
is informed and or somebody who isn't
Kenya can you do like a middle ground
and maybe hockey maybe you can get him
into hockey I guess you'd have to like
hockey if you don't like hockey because
it would have the physical aspects of it
but um those guys don't [ __ ] slam
into each other every play you know what
dude I don't know how to bring that up I
would just be honest with them and just
say listen I don't want to seem like a
cranky old man I don't want to seem like
a worried mother like you just said but
I'm really worried about the long-term
effects of you playing football and I
would even say long-term effects talk to
him like an adult just say yeah I am
worried that you know you if you get hit
the wrong way god forbid people get
paralyzed people die people have [ __ ]
don't say [ __ ] people have brain
injuries I would go down that road and
just I would just say to the kid your
concerns and if he really wants to
[ __ ] play then you know you just do
what Payton did you just get some roids
sent to your house you put them in your
wife's name and you get this kid you you
let him do a cycle right before the
season starts and you let him kick the
[ __ ] out of somebody else's kid not
yours right there you go okay
I'm just [ __ ] around obviously the
first thing I said I would I would seek
more information on that and figure out
how you do it in the best way all right
Peyton my house man dearest bill my
house needs painting
it has about six years it's been about
six years since it's been painted we
moved in four years ago I've painted a
house before by my wife thinks I'm going
to [ __ ] it up and or it will take too
long you know what I'm with her already
I've been telling her that I'll say
it'll save thousands of dollars she says
that's not the point
she's right it's not entirely the point
I make good money
I just want to paint the house it's my
first house and I feel the need to do
something to leave my mark on it
literally and figuratively speaking I'll
- it'll take me about three weeks to do
the whole house not working every day
but three four days a week I have a
neighbor who's going to be home from
college who I've introduced to music and
he's never heard well listen him to
music he's never heard so it's a great
excuse to give the kid a few bucks while
introducing him to early Soundgarden and
Jane's Addiction she started bringing
things up like well what if it starts
raining
she's got nothing left on this one I
have to paint my house it's not a manly
thing it's not to prove a point it's
taking pride and ownership thoughts on
this I say you listen to your life dude
you want to do some [ __ ] you finish
your garage do something like that
okay do something in there where it's a
room that she doesn't have to [ __ ]
deal with just have some pros come over
there have them knock it out have them
charge you through the [ __ ] nose and
you sit inside drinking a [ __ ] beer
all right this other [ __ ] that you can
do on the house you know I just paint in
the [ __ ] houses that's a big one dude
that is a big one I understand that you
want to do it but yeah I'm with you wife
on this one too you know you already got
a [ __ ] job okay you make it good
money pay somebody to do it all right
there's a bunch of [ __ ] on my house that
I started to do and I just started
thinking you know what I'm making a good
living [ __ ] this what I don't have a pro
come over I can do it I can figure I was
patching up holes in walls I was
learning how to do that [ __ ] you know I
was [ __ ] fixing the J trap under my
sink and doing all of that [ __ ] crap
they'd learned all of that [ __ ] my last
apartment then I got to the house and
it's like alright well I can do this or
I can have a pro come over here and do
it and do it [ __ ] right okay now I'm
speaking for myself here my house was
[ __ ] wall to wall wall floor to
ceiling inside and out Do It Yourself
[ __ ] hacks all right and
I wasn't gonna carry that [ __ ] baton
anymore everything that I had done on my
house has been done by [ __ ]
professionals and my house as much as I
[ __ ] about it it's seventy percent this
[ __ ] at this point it really is well
check it this garage done and then I got
on my kitchens [ __ ] up don't get me
started with all the exterior doors and
windows okay
in the wood rot and some of the other
[ __ ] I have to deal with but generally
speaking like this [ __ ] place is
solid and I don't know dude [ __ ] that
dude you don't go a [ __ ] ladder you
know I mean mixing the goddamn paint
doing all of that [ __ ] I would just
I would yeah just just pay for it just
pay for it and just say this fool is
what you do don't just do it just don't
do what your wife says get something out
of it all right be like all right you
know what I thought about it I don't
agree with it but I know that you would
feel better if somebody else did it okay
so I am going to hire a professional
company to paint the house and she's
like a good however because I am doing
that I am going to redo the garage and
the garage is gonna be a place where me
and my friends we play poker and we
smoke cigars once a week I'm gonna have
my own fridge in there there's going to
be a lock on the door that you do not
have a key for when you see exotic women
walking in and out of that you are not
to ask questions is this understood
right you just say crazy [ __ ] like that
right over the [ __ ] top and she's
done laughing then you say what the [ __ ]
you really want it will pale in
comparison to [ __ ] exotic women
walking in and out of your garage and
you'll be [ __ ] in so I would think
about what else you want all right at
the end of the [ __ ] day you're gonna
get something that you want somebody
else is gonna pay you how paint paint
your house I think you're gonna win
personally speaking that's what I think
all right and you know what that's the
podcast for this week mother thank you
for listening as always and I'm really
excited about all these dates that I
have coming up and I cannot [ __ ] wait
to go to Iowa I'm so excited about the
st. Louis some of the great [ __ ]
sports fans I've ever met my life are
insane
and God knows they got enough
Budweiser's Long Beach is [ __ ] the
goddamn [ __ ] Richard Pryor gig
Riverside Riverside California I [ __ ]
you know when I was learning out of fly
I had to die the land name I did the
[ __ ] French Valley flight I had to
fly to Riverside then out to French
Valley back to Long Beach [ __ ] I might
fly over there that would be awesome
Ames Iowa obviously cannot wait to go to
their Orlando I haven't been there in a
minute Jacksonville Florida last time I
was there I went to a gun gun range it
shut [ __ ] guns with silencers you
think I'm not gonna do that again
Portland May my old stomping grounds
Albany New York Newark New Jersey these
are all places I love all those places I
can't wait to get out there I've been
working my ass off of my act if you come
out I'm gonna make you laugh you [ __ ]
ass off okay so if you can make it I
would really appreciate it all right and
I'm actually trying to think of a tour
name if you can come up with a name for
it you know cuz these dates I'm in
Canada I'm in North America I'm in
[ __ ] you know what Canada's North
America I'm in the United States of
America right along the east coast I'm
in the Midwest I'm in the south I can't
think of a name for the tour I don't
know why I have to name tour but my
agent says I got to come up with a name
for it so I'm thinking the checking in
on your tour I don't know why if you
guys got on any ideas just tweet them to
me at bill burr whatever though I don't
know what my Twitter is you know I don't
even know what it is so whatever if you
got time to look it up send it to me if
you don't I understand go [ __ ]
yourselves we'll talk to you on Thursday